bonsoir guy moreau merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france clairement
quand on l'entend antoine claireaux nous
expliquer la situation sur le terrain
quand on l'entend
l'ambassadeur de russie à londres qui a
été convoqué les pays membres de l'otan
qui ont annoncé leur soutien à la
décision de washington de sanctionner la
russie on se dit qu'une escale à v est à
craindre
écoutez j'ai plutôt l'impression qu'on
est dans la situation inverse que
généralement avec les occidentaux
plus ils parlent fort mois ils ont
l'intention d'agir parce que ce qu'on a
observé aussi ces derniers temps je
souhaitais je crois il ya deux jours
c'est que l'attaché de presse du
président zelensky madame william handel
a déclaré que la solution de force pour
reprendre le don de base ce n'était pas
d'actualité
les deux bateaux de guerre américain qui
devait passer le détroit du bosphore
pour rejoindre la mer noire ont
finalement annulé leur passage et il est
clair que les la présence des troupes
russes à la frontière ukrainienne a
coupé l'envi des élites ukrainienne à
commencer par le président céline ski de
lancer une opération militaire sur le
dos de bath en tout cas pour l'instant
donc effectivement ce qu'on va continuer
à observer c'est ce qu'a voulu laisser
ce que voit votre journaliste à donetsk
c'est que cette espèce de harcèlement
des populations pour empêcher un retour
à la vie normale et bien qui consiste à
les bombarder envoyé des drones larguer
des grenades et tuer des enfants de 4
ans comme c'est arrivé il ya une semaine
mais je pense à mon avis que les que
l'escaladé plutôt en train dit
et que si je regarde ailleurs dans le
détail les sanctions que joe biden a
pris contre la russie en gros on sait
tout le monde s'y attendait plus ou
moins et c'est pas bien méchant c'est
pas bien méchant en tout cas le kremlin
juste que de nouvelles sanctions à
contre la russie bat n'allait pas
forcément favorisé l'organisation du
sommet que proposait joe biden à
vladimir poutine
ces sanctions justement c'est pas la
première fois il y en a plein qui ont
été prononcées en 2014 est ce qu'elles
portent leurs fruits en général à main
pour la com vous avait dit en février
2015 les sanctions seront peut-être là
une chance et dans ce cas la russie
depuis 1992
et ça a été le cas donc toutes les
sanctions russes et les contres
sanctions qui ont été prises par la
russie ont permis un décollage de la
delà de l'économie russe dans certains
domaines notamment le domaine agricole
mais pas seulement
et surtout la menace d'avoir par exemple
l'interdiction du swift 20 interdictions
de visa et mastercard
il ya tout ça a permis à la russie de
mettre en place son propre système il ya
maintenant un système qui remplace le
swift qui pourrait être à terme
connecter avec la chine justement sa
grille lavrov en a parlé il ya pas
longtemps
la russie veut vraiment sortir du dollar
et vous avez également bien là la carte
mère qui remplace la les visa mastercard
même si il faut bien le souligner visa
et mastercard ont déclaré hier ou
aujourd'hui qu'il voulait continuer à
travailler en russie qui n'était pas
question de partir donc je pense que ces
sanctions ne font pas grand mal ce qui
est un peu nouveau on peut le dire c'est
que désormais les obligations russes
donc d'état les institutions américaines
ne peuvent pas les acheter sur le marché
primaire n'ont en revanche peuvent aller
les acheter sur les marchés secondaires
ou et c'est sans doute ce qu'elles font
et ce qu'elles feront puisque de toute
manière les instituts américaine avait
acheté beaucoup moins de d'obligations
us qu'auparavant donc je pense que si
vous voulez pour que joe biden puisse
organiser une rencontre au sommet dans
un pays tiers avec poutine comme louis
le souhaitent
c'est bien la demande vient de joe
madden il faut qu'ils donnent du grain à
moudre
ces élites aux élites occidentales qui
attendent non pas une revanche après les
82 trump mais une vengeance les voiliers
même les néo conservateurs français ils
sont dans un état de rage poste trump et
ils ont besoin ils ont besoin de calculs
idol leur donne quelque chose et baydan
s'est rendu compte du show c'est qu'en
fait il n'a pas plus de poids sur
poutine et sur la russie que n'en avait
trump et que trump a mis les sanctions
qui ont qui doit pas trouver un marché
sur leur stream ii il a ralenti la la
construction du gazoduc de plus d'un an
et demi donc c'est pas si mal et
hebeisen ne peut pas faire grand chose
de plus
et je me demande si d'ailleurs cette
invitation de vladimir poutine un sommet
encore une fois dans un pays tiers n'est
pas une prise de conscience par une
partie de l'état profond et donc de son
représentant joe biden qu'il est trop
tard que désormais il va falloir
utiliser d'autres moyens que la menace
et la coercition et qu' il faut essayer
pour de vrai cette fois de faire un
reset avec la russie mais ça et bien
voilà on va le voir donner dans les
semaines qui viennent puisque y est
justement un discours de thomas hayden
qui est annoncé je pense qu'il faut
mettre en parallèle cette volonté de
discuter de joe biden et le fait qu'il
doit donner quelque chose
un public néo conservateurs démocrates
américains qui qui qui veut qui veut se
venger de la lumière poutine le kremlin
qui accuse aujourd'hui de la russie de
bouloire je cite la détruira la veille
un homme précise d'un sommet avec le
chef d'état ukrainien c'est une façon
quoi de faire monter la pression
d'obtenir des choses de l'occident
écoutez l'ukraine n'a pas besoin la
russie pour s'autodétruire
ça fait ça fait sept ans que ça dure et
je dirais d'ailleurs c'est ce que c'est
ce sur quoi la russie contre la russie
n'a aucun intérêt aujourd'hui à lancer
une offensive contre l'ukraine pourquoi
et bien parce que elle a trouvé en
allemagne un partenaire efficace et
loyal et on le voit notamment dans la
construction de nord stream 2 donc pour
la russie lancer une attaque contre
contre l'ukraine reviendrait à trahir
ses amis en allemagne et ses alliés
cesser les gens qui sont au pouvoir
c'est monsieur l'achète qui sera
peut-être qu'en dit la chancellerie où
c'est monsieur odeurs le président
ministres demain
qui lui aussi sera peut-être candidat
pour la céder au cs ou en allemagne donc
il ya énormément de députée soit de la
gauche avec die linke soit des gens de
l'alliance pour pour la pour l'allemagne
qui soutient la position russe et qui ne
comprendraient pas si la russie gachet
c'est ce partenariat qui pour l'instant
fonctionne allemagne pour l'instant
résiste aux menaces jo brydon veut
nommer un ambassadeur spécial monsieur
amos oz stein pour directement les
menaces et allemagne en fait c'est
quelqu'un qui va servir à les menacer
l'allemagne pour pas achever la
construction de nord stream de l'est
pour l'instant l'allemagne tient bon
donc évidemment la russie n'a aucun
intérêt à lancer l'opération contre
l'ukraine en ce moment et simplement
vlademir zelensky à l'intérieur de
l'ukraine a de gros problèmes avec tout
simplement avec ses mauvais résultats
avec le fait qu' il a trahi ses
engagements présidentiels et que
désormais les partis qui caracole en
tête ce sont des partis pro russe qui
l'a lui même sanctionné
il ya deux partis qui sont en train de
percer c'est le parti l'ukraine pour la
ville monsieur m'élever juke qui alors
qu'il est citoyen russe est sous
sanction l'ukraine c'est ce que
l'ukraine a inventé c'est à dire le les
sanctions contre ses propres citoyens et
également anatomy charrie qu'il ya un
parti qui en cas de succès auprès des
jeunes très efficace avec des activistes
très très motivé et c'est ça le punk
zelensky si lille est intérieure il
exactement le même que celui qui avait
son prédécesseur 4 ou porochenko il doit
faire monter la tension de manière
artificielle dans le bonne base pour
couvrir son échec quasi totale
économiques politiques stratégiques de
l'ukraine de kiev
merci xavier moreau directeur de strates
paul ii n'aura vous avoir apporté votre
analyse merci à vous